he just speak to the mechanism of how
humans believe
start to believe ideas is there
something interesting to say there from
your thinking about it
like how idea is born and how it takes
hold and how it spreads and how it
competes with other ideas first of all
ideas are an independent force in
history
marxists tend to deny that marxists
think that all history is just a play of
of material interests
and ideas stories they are just a smoke
screen to hide the underlying interests
my thoughts are to some extent the
opposite
we have some biological objective
interests that all humans share like we
need to eat
we need to drink we need to breathe
but most conflicts in history I'm not
about that
the interests which really Drive most
conflict in history don't come from
biology they come from religions and
ideologies and stories so it's not that
stories are a small smoke smoke screen
to hide the real interests the stories
create the interests in the first place
the stories Define who are the competing
groups
Nations religions cultures they are not
biological entities they are not like
species like gorillas and chimpanzees no
Israelis and Palestinians or Germans and
French or Chinese and Americans they
have no essential biological difference
between them the difference is cultural
it comes from stories there are people
that believe in different stories the
stories create the identity the stories
create the interests Israelis and
Palestinians are fighting over Jerusalem
not because of any material interest
there are no oil fields under Jerusalem
and even oil you need it to realize some
cultural fantasy it doesn't really come
from biology
so the stories are independent forces
now why do people believe one story and
not another That's History there is no
material materialistic law people will
always believe there's no history is
full of accidents
how did Christianity become the most
successful uh religion in the world we
can't explain it
so why why this story about Jesus of
Nazareth and not you know the Roman
Empire in the third Century uh CE uh was
a bit like I don't know California today
like so many sects and subjects and
gurus and religions like everybody has
their own thing yeah and you have you
know thousands of different stories
competing why did Christianity come up
on top as a historian I don't have a
kind of clear answer you can read the
sauces and you see how it it happens oh
this happened and then this happened and
then Constantine adopted this and then
this and then this but why
I don't think anybody has an as an
answer to that if you rewind the movie
of history and press play and you rewind
and plus pre press play a hundred times
I think Christianity would take over the
Roman Empire in the world maybe twice
out of a hundred times it was such an
unlikely thing to happen
and it's the same with Islam it's the
same I don't know it's the Communist
takeover of Russia
in 1914 if you told people that in three
years Landing in the Bolsheviks will
gain power in the sourest Empire they
would think you're utterly crazy
you know Lenin had a few thousand
supporters in 1914 in an Empire of close
to 200 million people
it sounded ludicrous
now we know the chain of events
the first world war the February
Revolution and so forth that led to the
Communist takeover but it was such an
unlikely event
and it happened and a little steps along
the way the little options you have
along the way because you know Stalin
versus Trotsky you could have thrabber
Frost poem there's always
and history often takes you know there
is a Highway and there is a kind of
sideway and history takes the sideways
many many times and is perhaps tempting
to tell some of that history through
charismatic leaders and maybe it's an
open question
how much power charismatic leaders have
to affect the trajectory of History
you've met quite a lot of charismatic
leaders lately I mean what's your view
on that I find it a compelling notion
I'm a sucker for a great speech and a
vision so I I have a sense that there's
an importance uh for a leader
to catalyze the viral spread of a story
as so like I think we need leaders to be
just great storytellers
um that kind of sharpen up the story to
make sure it infiltrates everybody's
brain effectively but uh it could also
be that
the local interactions between humans is
even more important it's just we don't
have a good way to sort of summarize it
and describe that
we like to talk about you know Steve
Jobs as Central to the development of
the computer maybe Bill Gates you you
you tell it's the stories of individuals
like this because it's just easier to
tell a sexy story that way maybe it's an
interplay because you have the kind of
structural forces
that I know you look you look at the
geography of the planet and you look at
shipping technology in late in the late
15th century in Europe and the
Mediterranean and it's almost inevitable
that pretty quickly somebody would
discover uh America somebody from the
old world will go to the New World
uh so this was not the kind of this
didn't if it wasn't Columbus then it
would have been a five years later
somebody else but
the key thing about history is that
these small differences make a huge huge
difference
you know if if it wasn't Columbus if it
was five years later somebody from
England then maybe all of Latin America
today would be speaking English and not
spanish if it was somebody from the
Ottoman Empire it's completely different
world history if you have and you know
the Ottoman Empire at that time was also
shaping up to be a major Maritime Empire
if you have America uh uh Rich being
reached by Muslim Navigators before
Christian Navigators from Europe you
have a completely different world
history
it's the same as the computer
given them economic incentives and the
Science and Technology of the time then
the the rise of the personal computer
was probably inevitable sometime in the
late 20th century but the where and when
is crucial the fact that it was
California in the 1970s and not say I
don't know Japan in the 1980s or China
in the 1990s this made a huge huge
difference so you have this interplay
between the structural forces which are
beyond the control of any single
charismatic leader but then the the
small changes they can have a big effect
and I think for instance about the ball
in Ukraine there was a moment now it's
now it's a struggle between nations
but there was a moment when the decision
was taken in the mind of a single
individual of Vladimir Putin and he
could have decided otherwise and the the
the world would look completely
different
and uh another leader Volare zalanski
could have decided to leave Kiev in the
early days there's a lot of decisions
that kind of Ripple yeah